Let's make a function for printing that takes in
a width and height in centimeters for the photo or picture we want to print.
Like this picture of Duke,
who's the Java mascot.
We also want our function to have a parameter for a boolean inColor.
InColor should be true for color prints and false for black and white ones.
Then we want our function to print out a description of this print.
This function called printPhoto,
takes in these three parameters width, height and inColor.
And you can include even more than this,
as long as you separate the parameters with commas.
So we can include more information like a string for
texture or float for price and so on,
but let's stick with these three parameters for now.
To color printPhoto function for different sizes and colors it prints,
we have to provide the three pieces of information that
this function expects in the order that specified.
First we have an int argument that will correspond to our width parameter.
Then we have another int argument that will
correspond to our height parameter and finally,
a third boolean describing whether this print should be in color or not.
We can describe a 30 cm by 40 cm color photo by calling printPhoto with 30,
40 and true as our arguments.
Again, these arguments are matched to
the type and order of parameters in the function definition.
Our first argument 30 is to match with our first parameter and width.
Our second argument 40 is matched to our second parameter and height,
and our third argument true is matched to our third parameter boolean inColor.
For this function call,
we'll have this print output.
Java will see these arguments and enter a function definition.
It will print out 30 for the width,
40 centimeters for the height and then because inColor is true,
print is full color.
The order that we put these arguments into our function call
is really important which we'll see in more detail next.